created by the cable television industry
the book you see on your screen is
titled treason by the book
it explains the conspiracy trial behind
an attempted chinese coup during the
18th century
next author jonathan spence discusses
the research he completed to tell the
story it's a little over an hour 10
minutes and it's this week's feature in
our continuing series of books on
history
okay it's wonderful for you all to join
us here tonight
for those of you who don't come to our
program often i would like to let you
know you can sign up for our monthly
mailing list we have about 15 events
each month you can also get that list on
the worldwide web and that address is
www.capitolablecafe.com
so either way we hope to see you back
here soon
tonight though we are very pleased and
we are quite honored to welcome jonathan
spence to the area he is a highly
respected professor at yale university
and one of the leading western
historians on ancient and modern china
his work includes 12 books ranging from
a short biography on mao to wonderfully
specific works on the death of woman
wang and the mystery palace of matteo
ricci
regardless of the subject matter
jonathan spence i think writes with
grace and candor rendering the most
intricate chinese customs beliefs and
battles comprehensible even magical to
unfamiliar readers
his awards include a guggenheim and a
macarthur fellowship
but these commendations i think only
hint at the magnitude of his intellect
and his passion for the subject matter
it is indeed a great honor to have him
here in santa cruz county tonight he
joins us here to discuss a rather odd
tale of imperial tyranny and
disgruntled scholars treason by the book
is his newest work and it really details
an 18th century rebellion and a dialogue
between its rebel leader zhang jing
and the manchu emperor at the time yang
zhing
this conversation kind of back and forth
was later published in book form in
china under the title awakening the
delusion
and was made mandatory reading
throughout the country in order to give
the emperor his back his power
the beginning of this extraordinary tale
really takes place in october in 1728
when a treacherous letter is delivered
to general yu in the hopes that this
general will join in a rebellion to
restore the native ming dynasty to power
and really revolt against the current
man true reign
general yu initially says well of course
not he refuses but then he goes along
with this really to get the names of his
co-conspirators um 13 names in all are
divulged and they live throughout the
country in various provinces which of
course raises the shackles on our
emperor and brings a great investigation
to pass this takes months and the story
goes on from there
to watch how the emperor responds in the
18th century
and the extreme punishment that he uses
to both family members and confucian
scholars is to better understand the
story of absolute rule in china to see
its past is to understand its present
treason by the book is a small
masterpiece constructed through many
primary sources and with an intellectual
passion that i think only jonathan
spence possesses
please join me now in welcoming him to
the book cafe
[Applause]
well thank you very much that's that's
the summary i was going to give you so
uh
i don't know we should move straight
into q a a what but uh i'll try my
version of that perhaps for a little bit
but that was uh actually caught some of
the essence of the of the tale
what i'd like to do is read a little bit
to start us off and then have some of my
own commentary then read a little more
uh and then let you all ask questions
about whatever you want to ask about in
in this story okay
um because the introduction laid out
they laid out the sort of the time and
the chronology
very nicely uh i'll i'll i'll just um
give it my spin perhaps since i spent a
lot of time with these with these
documents
but it is true that this is a a case of
treason uh as the title says in large
letters and it was a treason case
entirely planned by school teachers
and as a school teacher i got very
interested in how school teachers might
try and kill the emperor
and it turned out indeed to be
sort of both learned but also very
bookish and really rather clueless in
the long run
uh and i think that the teachers had
read too much about um how to how to
rise up they
they got too learned about the solutions
they sought
they also wrote everything down which is
not good if you're a traitor
it's really i would urge you if your
trace is not to write everything down
because their bookishness uh
spread you know all through their their
very being and uh
they also read of course classical
chinese texts with with great passion
partly because they had to uh in china
of the 18th century as in many other
centuries you you had to marshal the
books of the past
in order to pass the lowest level of
examinations which alone brought success
usually from from those among the common
people who were trying to rise in the in
the bureaucracy so this was a bookish
society uh dominated by examinations for
the elite uh in which the the the
meaning of of language was it was
important to the scholars at the time
and that's why i called it treason by
the book and i mean that to be about a
quadruple pun they doing things by the
book means we do them rather precisely
but it's treason expressed in a book
it's trees and drawing on the books of
the past
uh and ultimately as as the introduction
mentioned the emperor himself created a
book out of the whole case
which makes it i think perhaps one of
the oddest books
in chinese history one of the most
interesting and curious books because in
a sense it's half written by the emperor
of china and half written by the man who
tried to kill him
well so this was a teacher's plot uh the
teachers for those of you here from
china who probably know this this story
or its outline the teacher was from
hunan province south east hunan
near the jiangxi border that's south of
the yangtze river below the city of
changsha
and and so they were country scholars
they weren't on the national grid at all
and indeed the chief conspirator later
said that he'd only once been to a big
town uh sort of insight that i hadn't
understood before about his his life
the plot bursts on the sort of national
scene in
1728 in in october 1728
and i want to start the way i start my
my story to see if you
uh like the way i start my story uh with
the way that the plot first surfaced and
the plot came to light again the author
has to decide how to proceed of course
with every book in history like in any
other book
uh and obviously the plot had been
hatching for years in the minds of these
teachers and their students and also
uh other people had thought of similar
plots to overthrow uh the dynasty
but this particular moment in in october
1728 is when it surfaces
and as i began writing this book i don't
usually have an elaborate synopsis and i
i do have to tell my students that i
can't tell them to prepare a normal
synopsis of everything they're writing
because i like it to grow as i write i
don't i don't have a huge outline and
fill it in i want to see how the story
grows
and in this case the story grew for me
actually as i was writing the bit i'll
read to you now the prologue i suddenly
realized that what i wanted to do and
and this is what i've done in this book
uh is let you the reader um follow the
story along with the emperor of china i
want the reader in a sense to know no
more than the emperor knew at any one
given point so i want to start use the
reader off where the emperor came in
and then i never want to let you get
ahead of the emperor and ultimately the
emperor knew the whole story in great
detail as if you wish to read the book
you will know the story in great detail
but you won't be able to have a sort of
a simple and easy flashback system to
get you all straightened out
because
treason plots like many other kinds of
story emerge in bits and pieces tiny
hints here and there leads
a strange event strange coincidences
sort of interlocking bits of evidence
and and this is the way the emperor
began to put it together
the only other thing i think i need
mentioned before looking at the prologue
is that
uh the site the place where this
happened is in sian in in shaanxi
province south of the yellow river
and those who have been to china would
almost certainly have seen the great
terracotta warriors i can see lots of
people nodding uh they they are in that
city that's where the very near there
are the tombs of the great early chin
emperors uh and this this area had been
china's capital for for many years uh
under the the name of chang
and chang is is
and that is the modern
city that we now go to as tourists
it's also preserved its walls i think
better than any other city in china
so you can get some sense of what a qing
dynasty city was like
the only dates i'll give you i think in
the whole talk would be that the qing
dynasty
was founded in 1644
by destroying a previous dynasty the
famous ming dynasty famous for its
porcelain the wonderful blue and white
porcelain but also a a chinese uh
dynasty a dynasty controlled and founded
by the han h a and chinese
whereas the 1644 conquerors were manchus
who were regarded by the han chinese as
interlopers if not as barbarians at
least certainly as outsiders
who came in and broke up the traditional
chinese civilization so many chinese
mourned that conquest they regretted it
deeply
and they had a strong sense of being
chinese in a way that the manchus could
not be could never be
and they yearn to overthrow them so this
conspiracy case is partly based on that
on that fact
uh and the fact that it was the ancient
capital of china is rather intriguing in
this context though it probably wasn't
essential to the way the plot uh
developed
the only name i think we need from the
prologue is uh general yue who is
mentioned in the introduction ue
is the commanding general the commandant
of chinese armed forces in the north
west at this time
uh in the provinces of shanxi and sachon
and he was a tough korea officer who was
a chinese ethnic chinese and his uh
ancestors five centuries before had been
china's most famous patriot uh called
ufa uh who had helped try and support
the sung dynasty against the jinn
barbarians from the north so
right from the very beginning we're
plunged in a certain bookish use of the
past by the conspirators okay so we got
the sight of the city of sian we got
general yue as the main actor
uh you will find you'll you'll you'll
find briefly somebody called mao but
don't be alarmed it's not mao zedong
it's not an ancestor of mao it is just
somebody who got caught up in the plot
who happened to be called mao
which is not a particularly rare
name in in china
okay this is how those who well if
you've read any of my things before i i
like to create a narrative style as i go
a little draw as much information as
possible together as accurately as
possible based on sources from the time
so
the the prologue is drawn entirely from
several overlapping reports issued in
1728 to the emperor china had a great
communication system fast uh swift
secretive and and we can certainly talk
about that in in discussion if you'd
like to
um
so the what i'm going to summarize now
is my drawing together from these
different reports uh as they were later
to to reach the emperor and so this is
how i
i bring you in the story and introduce
the idea of treason okay so i call this
the prologue and then its subtitle is
the letter
the letter
the man holding the letter stands by the
side of the road at the foot of the drum
tower gazing down the long avenue that
stretches straight through the city of
sian to the closely guarded west gate a
mile away
to his left the view is blocked by lofty
walls those of the spacious compound
that serves as office and residence to
the governor general of the western
provinces
that is why the man has chosen this spot
to wait
he knows that yuejung qi the current
governor general of the region is
attending an official reception at one
of the pavilions out in the suburbs
beyond west gate and will be returning
down this road to his compound as soon
as the morning ceremony is over
that will be the time to act
the waiting man is alone though he has
not planned it that way
before he even began his journey he was
told by his teacher that in a village
some miles upriver from sian he would
find a sure accomplice
a respected scholar named mao
who shared the plotter's views and had
money for the cause
but when he reached mao's home he found
only two of mao's sons living there both
of whom were farmers
they informed him that their scholar
father had died six years before and
that there was nothing they could do to
help at all
and then there was the letter carrier's
own cousin an apparent believer in the
quest who traveled all the way with him
from the south to carry his baggage and
keep him company
but two days ago the cousin panicked now
that the moment was so close and fled
without warning back to the south
taking one of the bedrolls and much of
their baggage
so now there is no one to share the
anxious watcher's thoughts
it is almost noon when at last general
u.s sedan chair with its accompanying
retinue of bearers and outriders can be
seen making its way back along west
street
the man waits until they're almost
opposite the drum tower before running
towards them across the road brandishing
his letter in the air
instinctively us retainers shout at the
man to stop and they form a protective
ring around their general to block the
stranger from approaching any closer
from the seat of his sedan chair general
yue stares out at the scene
this stranger is not dressed like the
ordinary government underlings and
office clerks bustling around with
correspondence for their superiors with
whom the general so often conducts his
business
nor does this man act like them there is
something unusual about his demeanor
without leaving his chair
ue makes a decision
he calls out to his retainers to bring
him the letter the man is clutching
they do so and general ue glances at the
envelope
a single look is all he needs to realize
that he's in serious trouble
if this were an official letter dealing
with some detail of government it would
address him by his full name and title
as
governor general of the provinces of
shansi and sichuan
or perhaps as commanding general of the
western armies
but this letter instead is addressed to
the commander-in-chief deputed by heaven
in suspicious times such as those ua
lives in
such a superscription is itself a danger
sign
ordering the retainers to arrest the
stranger and hold him for questioning ua
goes to his office and tells the staff
there to leave him undisturbed
when they are gone he opens the envelope
and begins to read
on the opening page the writer of the
letter identifies himself not with the
name
but by mysterious title
summer calm
the leaderless widow when sorry the
leaderless wanderer of the southern seas
the writer further states that the
messenger who will deliver the letter to
the general is named zhang the luminous
as to the letter itself everything is
his journal has guessed and feared
a few lines suffice to show him that the
contents are undiluted treason
well that was how it began
uh with this letter from a stranger with
a pseudonym in an envelope apparently
written by somebody else
and the general after reading it
was in a predicament that really
triggers the whole thing because the
intelligence system was so effective in
china under emperor yongjung uh
news was sent so swiftly to the capital
that general uh
knew that even if he didn't report this
event his friends would
uh and there was no way they would not
that their careers were on the line
because some strange man had given an
unknown letter to the general who'd read
it in private and in this society that
was known uh rapidly
and indeed the news had spread probably
before he'd finished the letter
and so his only hope is to start
questioning the messenger immediately
and to try to find out who these strange
pseudonyms refer to
and what on earth is going on
uh he also has the information that is
in the letter itself which was really
startling the letter that he just been
reading in the privacy of his own study
and note that he sent everybody away
before even opening it he tells him for
later he did that
this letter was basically in content a
sustained attack on the emperor of china
emperor jungjeong who ruled from 1723 to
1735 so this was after yongjung was five
years on the throne because we're in the
year 1728.
the charges in that letter were
astonishingly frank and violent
they included the fact that the manchu
people who ruled china were usurpers and
conquerors illegitimate conquerors of
the chinese people and had seized the
country by illegal force by improper
force
they included the charge that jung jung
himself was an extremely bad ruler as
his ancestors had been and that he
himself was the usurper of the throne
even as the manchu race had observed the
whole nation of china in other words uh
they the letter said that he had taken
the throne from his own brothers
it pointed out that he'd killed three of
his own brothers to seize the throne um
in the letter it accused him of a whole
range of sexual uh malpractice and and
sexual uh greed uh and including taking
women from his own brothers uh among
their consort
uh and also um creating havoc with the
previous consults from his own father
these were
terrible charges he was accused of being
cruel beyond all conceivable necessity
and also of avarice of greed
which was doubly unnecessary because he
was obviously the richest person on the
planet so why be so greedy when you own
the forbidden city in the summer palace
and all these things these were the
charges in the letter
and the letter was just suffused with
anger of a kind that we could either
call perhaps racialist
or ethnic hatred of a hatred for chinese
writer against the manchu people
and it became clear that the letter
writer wanted to restore chinese rule
over his own country
and set the clock back 80 years to the
time before the conquest by the manchus
it was for this reason for all these
reasons that the emperor
knew
when he was informed about this
the general ue was also being wooed
because he had this patriotic lineage
going right back five centuries uh to
the famous ufa
and we know from other sources that
emperor yongjung did indeed know this
that he knew that chinese were saying
ufa might be the ancestor of yuejung chi
so the chinese will rise up uh and the
emperor had actually told general yue
that he the emperor knew this but he
still trusted him to stay loyal
and some of the sources reinforce that
now we can't go through all the details
i just want to sketch in what happened
and then we can go to two questions
the follow-up was immediate and very
thorough and and having uh sort of
got so absorbed by the sources by this
time i realized that what i was actually
interested in as much as anything else
in this
was the investigative procedures that
were followed so
uh one or two people have already said
this was a bit like a mystery novel or a
spy story that's fine with me uh because
i wanted to see how the bits and pieces
of the story were drawn together
because there was nothing to go on this
letter gave nothing specific to go and
it was like a huge shadowy series of
attacks character assassination maybe
with a whole lot of pseudonyms
but it only took uh the general ua a few
days
to to to break through the messengers
resistance
torture didn't work
this man
withstood torture so awful
that the general actually told the
emperor that they had to stop where the
man would have been killed
and so he just wasn't gonna say anything
so this must have a strong bond to the
leader of the conspiracy uh because they
were not gentle with him uh but so they
tricked him uh the
the general finally uh summoned the the
tortured messenger back
and said he'd been thinking about the
letter
and he realized it was essential to
throw in his lot with the conspirators
at which the messenger was so moved
that he said okay
if you're really join us and then
uh you a general said well tell me all
about this and the man said well only if
you swear a great oath never to divulge
anything to anybody
and the general must have thought and he
really only had a split second he said
yes and he swore at last we don't have
the oath but it must have been a
terrible oath a very strong
uh which sort of haunted him the rest of
his life because he broke it
once he got news about the whole
conspiracy
the general broke the oath and sent the
information to his emperor and so it
went racing across china to beijing
where emperor young chung had the news
within just under two weeks
and he responded swiftly
as different in fact the general was
sending as an express courier every day
for a breathtaking period of time or
every other day in fact
in october and early november
and by the middle of the month the
emperor had enough to to go on and he
knew the real names of the messengers
teacher who was indeed a school teacher
was a bookish man in southeast hunan and
once that was all put together and other
parts of the plot placed people in
different parts of china including
province on the east coast of china
but mainly in hunan and jejung the
emperor sends special squads down to
each of these cities under top secret
orders to surround all the to locate and
surround all the houses of the named
conspirators
of whom as the introducer said to her
ultimately 13 who were real people not a
very large number but the plot had
seemed so huge because they wrote such a
good letter
and they had so much veiled information
and hints of their power and what lay
ahead for them i mean these arrests went
off without a hitch and they were a
formidable piece of of
orchestration of police maneuvering now
all the different people were
interrogated for a long time and nearly
all those interrogations have survived
in chinese files uh in the in the arc
and so they're available for for
scholars
and so the emperor had all this material
pouring into beijing
and uh early in the next year by
the spring of 1729 he ordered all the
conspirators brought to to beijing
i should mention that by the law of the
time all the conspirators families were
arrested at the same time everybody
grandparents parents children
grandchildren
and except for the principles they were
all held in in the prisons of the county
magistrate in the area where they
happened to have been arrested the
principles were sent to beijing and in
the case of
as the key uh conspirator was named uh
his mother and children were sent to
beijing as well and were imprisoned
well it's to this stage that a series of
extraordinary things happen which i can
elaborate on if you want to in the
discussion but i'll just mention what
they were here
um one was that once the interrogation
had proven
uh that obviously zhang jing was the
leader of this conspiracy and they found
out exactly who the messenger was and
what had been going on in these people's
minds
the emperor could at any stage in all
this have killed the conspirator and the
and the accomplices and there would have
been no case
and we wouldn't be here
though all these people would have died
instantly for treason and and that could
be commonly done would have been done
except the emperor decided not to do it
and so it leads us into another part of
all this that besides police procedure
and the history of the time
we can really study the character of an
emperor in action as he tries to decide
what to do
about treason and the actions that yong
jung took to me was so interesting as a
historian
that they they fully kept me going
charged up as i wrote this book
the first thing he did once uh
the prisoner was safely the leader tsung
and he's the only one i'll concentrate
on now once he was safely in prison in
beijing having been thoroughly
interrogated and these interrogations
were all on record
the emperor began what i can only call a
series of seminars
with the conspirators
in which he wrote to him at regular
intervals the two never met these two
men never met they were exactly the same
age which is one of those curious
coincidences the son of heaven and the
small town school teacher were just the
same age they were in their mid-40s when
the case began they were 50 when it
ended
but he began to send messages through
his staff to to zhengcheng to the
conspirator in which he took item by
item the charges the violent charges in
the letter
and then sent why call them seminars is
because the emperor sent the chief
conspirator in prison
the documentary evidence that would
enable him
to realize that his charges had been
wrong
i'll only give one example and we can
elaborate again if you'd like to for
instance one of the charges had been
that the emperor yung jung was
needlessly cruel
uh and paid no attention to the law okay
it was one of the many churches and
there were many violent ones but that
they harped a lot on his cruelty the
emperor's delight in killing people what
emperor youngjung did was he took 10
cases 12 cases in which
he as emperor had reviewed cases of
capital punishment cases of homicide in
which people were sentenced to death
and there was in fact a review system in
the in the chinese empire not always
followed but that the emperor could in
fact
scrutinize capital cases and
in this case the emperor sent 12 cases
in which he had reviewed cases in which
people were just about to be executed
and had ordered the
um sentence lighten
either because of procedural
improprieties or because he saw that the
evidence was not as thorough or because
he saw something wrong with the way the
law had been applied
and the emperor made zhang jing read all
these cases and then he sent him a
letter saying do you think i'm so cruel
if i'm so cruel all the time why should
i
mitigate the death sentence for these
people who've obviously done wrong uh
you know but you tell me and so of
course zhang jing eventually wrote back
saying well yeah you don't seem as cruel
as i thought now i've read these cases
uh and then he said you govern the
conservatives said you govern the empire
very badly youngjung sent him a huge
array of bureaucratic papers uh on
confidential matters and explained how
long it took to read these how complex
they were he sent and then he repeated
the
the episode sending over 200
confidential documents to zhang jing and
then he asked for an evaluation of them
and zhong jing writes back and saying
you work a lot harder than i thought
and the emperor said thank you uh i do
indeed other we know from other scholars
that this emperor probably worked 16
hour days all his life on the throne it
wasn't just you know play in the
forbidden city with his chosen consorts
not at all he was a bureaucrat working
around the clock to run a country with
about 160 million people by this time
so uh this and many other things went on
through that seminar
uh at the end of it uh zheng jing had
answered all the and had withdrawn he'd
answered the emperor and he'd withdrawn
his his accusations on a whole series of
fronts
at the same time the investigation had
been going on into other conspirators
and more and more had appeared and so on
all over china
until the emperor had a very good handle
on what was going on
and once the some of these other
investigations continue all through the
book indeed till the end of the book
because the emperor never rested because
there are always more leads to follow up
uh especially because he believed that
every rumor should be tracked to its
source
and this is a story full of rumors so
the emperor's point was that
rumor mongers are worse than the people
who believe the rumors
and he began to tilt in the direction of
saying zhang jing had been misled
and he the emperor wanted to know who
the misleaders were in other words he
shifted
and he has some wonderful statements i
think they're wonderful in the book in
which he says
um
you know
you can always find the origin of a
rumor there is no rumor without an
origin however horrible it is and that
origin is going to be a person
and it doesn't matter how long it takes
but somebody told you that and then
somebody told them that and they were
told by somebody else and eventually
we'll find it out and in a surprising
amount of cases the qing dynasty police
and agents would track these down one by
one and they'd finally find the
originator uh and probe his motives for
for starting
well in the middle of all this
investigation in the in the late um
summer early fall of 1729.
uh the emperor declared that
that zheng jing was absolutely guilty of
high treason everything was proven
and he was going to pardon him
now that
opened the next sort of shock to me and
completely unexpected to me
the emperor said we will pardon
this man totally
and instead of just
accepting this as i thought people would
do in china for the son of heaven
the senior bureaucrats
objected violently
violently
and they wrote to me one of the most
fascinating documents about
administration the problems of somebody
in power but under a very powerful
person otherwise the executive level
bureaucrats people trying to run the
country under the sun of heaven
they pointed out that if the emperor
pardoned zhang jin when he was proven to
be guilty of the highest possible
treason
what were they to do about administering
the law in the future
how would they to punish anybody when
those people in china could say but look
you just pardoned this guy zhang jing
who insulted and tried to kill the
emperor why what about poor little me
i'm just a trivial person and so they
begged the emperor to withdraw the
pardon
uh and he refused in in a public edict
as it was called
and then the bureaucrats to my even
greater surprise tried again and this
document has been preserved as well this
time
148 of the most senior bureaucrats in
china wrote a petition to emperor
yongjung all signing their names and
their full titles it's a huge long
document extraordinary document in which
they beg the emperor not to do this for
the second time
and they and they repeat their story and
then they add various arguments to it
this is just not the way to govern the
country there's a time when mercy
doesn't make sense
um and that was picked up by the emperor
it was read
and he repeated he said he'd thought
about this carefully and he decided that
history had to be the judge so of course
i was delighted to read that
so he said let history be the judge uh
i will tolerate no more discussion on
this you get on with your business i'll
get on with mine uh and then the people
of the future can say either you were
right or i was right but anyway zhunjing
is going to be a pardon uh and we'll all
get on with running the country
um that was followed by the again
equally startling decision uh to give uh
zhang jing a job
uh so the emperor even thought about
sort of rehabilitation into the society
he arranged for him to have an excellent
job well-paying job in changsha back in
hunan
he released his mother from prison and
his children
and sent them back to hunan not long
after he gave an enormous cash gift to
zhengjin to set him up back in his
ancestral place
a gift enormous for the money of the
time you know if you're interested it
was over a thousand ounces of silver
uh where when 10 ounces a year would
have been a big salary for the for
people in the countryside so that's a
hundred people's full income just as a
cash price from the emperor
to to help buy some land and look after
his family as the empress
and so zhong jing went home with all
these marks of honor while the emperor
went on to publish a transcript of the
entire trial and the seminar which was
then ordered distributed all across
china and we know from various chinese
archival sources that this book was
published printed in the palace in
beijing and circulated across china and
then reprinted on the emperor's orders
by every single senior official so if
any of you have been the military
recipients of a chain letter this is
essentially what happened each copy
spawned another hundred copies respond
another hundred copies and we're pretty
sure that several hundred thousand
copies had circulated by the 1731.
one notation even shows us a copy
reaching taiwan
which shows how firmly taiwan was now
incorporated in the qing state
and the administrator in taiwan said
they would need hundred one thousand two
hundred more copies
to be printed so we can gauge how many
students there were in taiwan at the
time just to me it seems we can i think
there were probably 1200 advanced
students on the island of taiwan uh by
the year 1731. one reached general who
said thank you very much uh because he
found all his confidential information
now shared around the whole country uh
including various charges against
himself that that were not flattering
so but the book was spread everywhere
the man was pardoned uh and the and the
conspirator was left with with it with a
fine job
um all the way through the rest of his
life the emperor was tracking down
rumors and zheng jing was trying to tidy
up the case
and people were debating the value of
this approach to to morality
the only thing that people hadn't
exactly thought of perhaps was that
emperors die and uh emperor yongjung
died in in 1735
and his son who then became the next
emperor
didn't agree with his father
but i'm not going to tell you what he
said
okay you have to read the chapter to
find out
so that's my summary and now i think we
can take questions okay
i won't read another passage let's just
let you have
questions i'll start right here and then
move back maybe
how difficult was it to
gather all of this material wasn't it
yeah how difficult to gather the
material that's
that's a the very basic question um it
turned out not to be
desperately hard once one got the idea
um i mean when one had to hunt and do
some work uh as a historian but the the
the basic um
the the book the transcript of the case
had survived though though for various
reasons so very few copies left partly
because of what happened after the
emperor died
but this book had later became an
embarrassment to the rulers but a few
copies survived so we have a transcript
of these trials and so on
and the trouble with that was we only
had the you know the transcript that had
appeared at the time and one couldn't
necessarily be sure
how accurate all these documents were
but
in about um 1993
the palace museum in beijing published a
photo transcript
of what were called the official court
diaries of the young zhang reign for
chinese here it's called
the the diaries of a
repose and uh activity and repose the
special these were special diarists from
the scholarly class from the hanlin
academy uh and in those diaries which i
which i was able to read i mean you know
at yale they were published in a photo
offset so it's exactly like photocopy
the original
one could track all the all the um
i find my great delight one can track
all the things that turned up in that in
the volume of the of from 17 30 17 20.
uh and so we can we get a double check
there then the the archives in beijing
and taiwan the chinese archives are
split because of the civil war
and when zhang kai-shek went to taiwan
in 1949
he actually took as many of the archives
as he could
so that the nationalist party in taiwan
would control the past which
gives you legitimacy in chinese politics
so there's very very rich archives in
taipei um
and they include um
among other things which i went to see
in person because i just couldn't
believe it existed but i happened to be
in taiwan anyway but i went to the
palace museum and asked if i could see
it it was actually zhengjing's letter of
thanks to the emperor for his cash gift
and i said i can't just go on here you
know i've got to see it and it was
brought by a friendly archivist and i
sat in taipei reading this conspirators
thank you letter to that was really
magical
and so these documents exist and then
the taiwan authorities first
and then followed by the beijing palace
museum staff published again a photo
trans you know photo copies of of their
key archives and uh
they haven't got to the modern age but
luckily for me they did the young
jungeren and the kang shirai and his
father and chien long his son and so
on the young jung rain we have about um
20 volumes about a thousand pages each
of the
incoming secret reports with the empress
notation
and scattered all through these volumes
this emperor was a very busy man but
scattered through
the the volumes from beijing which is
slightly more about 26 volumes i think
about the same length
scattered through them uh
we i was able to fight well with the
help of research staff i hasten to add
we were able to find about 153 secret
documents on the case in fact not about
153
some of which were 15 pages long written
meticulously carefully about the senior
bureaucrats and often double checking
each other and then there are various
other sources of other kinds of
richness so
uh it was i mean it was you know hard
but honest toil and uh
it was made possible by the the terrific
archivists in both taiwan and and
beijing so
uh another side is that there was a very
successful tv show on yeongjung emperor
in uh in china uh in in which showed i
think in 98 and 99 uh and was very
popular
uh so much so that i think it was it was
it 28 uh episodes it was very long
it was a bit soap like from the parts i
saw but it was it was also historically
you know pretty good
um like some other tv shows we get i
think on you know info documentaries
whatever they call
but this uh
this was so interesting in china that
actually a publishing company produced a
a um
a punctuated version of the
emperor's transcript of the case that
the book is
the chinese here would know called
the
it's the book to celebrate the awakening
from delusion that the coming back to
reality uh is the title it was given
and so
uh actually the chinese response i mean
in you know the current chinese
government in the mainland's response to
the public interest in the in in the in
the young emperor was to for a local
publisher to produce this very difficult
text in a slightly more uh accessible
version in chinese and and so people
must have been buying this i'm not sure
in this country we would always race to
buy you know a thousand pages of
documents to back up a popular tv show
about george washington i'm not sure we
would
but certainly in china this was a hot
seller and i was lucky enough to get a
copy i just happened to be in china at
the time so i suddenly saw daiichuyemilu
in the bookstore
like that
and it had some backup documents within
so that that brought it out in a
slightly broader level and then there's
been a little scholarship by westerners
but actually very little it didn't
attract much attention
um
so maybe i'll jump back and then come
forward again right at the back yeah
yes the oh okay the question i'll repeat
the question each time
yeah the question was how did he
approach the the charges that the
manchurian government was illegitimate
and how did he handle that right
the the emperor spent a lot of time
handling that trying to think it through
um
and and he
pretty much explained it like this which
was he spent a lot of time uh lecturing
his conspirator on history
and lecturing the chinese people
his basic point was that the it was
certainly true that the ming dynasty was
run by chinese by han chinese and he
uses that phrase
it was a chinese dynasty it had existed
ever since 1368.
uh the the manchu emperor said the
trouble with
those those ming people was that they
had
run out of energy they'd run out of uh
moral energy particularly they were
losing their great old habit you know
great ill customs and they were no
longer running their country as well as
they should have done
uh at which point uh the emperor said in
his lecture to the chinese people at
which point the ming dynasty was
overthrown
not by the manchus but by
chinese domestic rebels which in fact is
true liza chang and
um jiangxianjung and a whole group of
chinese rebels rose in the 1640s
and jointly uh disrupted much of the
chinese government and in
1644 the the bandit leader called lee
liz
actually sees beijing
at which point the ming emperor
committed suicide the last ming emperor
leaving a whole lot of fugitive emperors
or claimants to to run around for about
20 more years but the legitimate emperor
was killed jung jung said it was at this
point that we manchus came in to restore
you people to order
you obviously couldn't do it yourselves
so we came in as
essentially saviors of the nation and
you should be
done lucky we did uh because we
respected the chinese traditions and
it's true the manchu rulers began to
learn chinese and jung jong writes you
know incredibly fluent chinese um i'm
told by manchester scholars he he also
writes good manchu but i don't know i
can't read match
but the um most of the court was now
proceeding in chinese by this time and
yong jing said look we've we've just
become the sort of the chinese rulers
that you in a sense gave up being able
to be
but we have the same interests as your
previous rulers don't don't accuse us of
being bad emperors because we're working
our hearts out for you people you know
and that's why he showed them how much
work he did and and
so it's a very moralistic
self-justification but it's not
it's not inaccurate it's it's it's a
twist on the past but
the basic things that young chung said
are fairly good descriptions of you know
in a very capsule like form of what
happened
and he then joins a lot of chinese
scholars who had
indeed bemoaned what i guess we would
you know in this country or in the
chinese themselves would call the kind
of moral degeneration uh in the late
ming he'd say the country is just
getting soft it's getting rotten in
terms of ethics you know we'd it's just
got to be tightened up we've got to
restore the school system we got to have
people better trained we got to learn
the confusion classics better we've got
to have more rigorous examination and
all these things the manchester they
held examinations right away in chinese
they just allowed a few manchus to take
them if they could master the chinese
tradition
they restored order to the country they
expanded china by seizing taiwan which
had not been part of china before in an
official way
they sent chinese troops into tibet
which had not been done for a very long
time and later they moved chinese troops
into what later became xinjiang you know
so they were expanding as many scholars
now point out under the manchu congress
china doubled in size
and that's the size it is now
so anybody now in china is actually a
beneficiary of manchu conquest and
expansion with the exception of taiwan
which makes that such a stormy issue
but otherwise they pretty much
re-coalesced and also the exception of
mongolia which is now a separate
republic but it was it was a very
careful historical justification and i'm
not really well i won't go through all
the other things but the emperor wrote
about it a lot and he comes back to it
all through his life
so he's he's he's feeling a bit upset by
being told he has no right to be the son
of heaven
maybe um
yes okay yes
i'm just interested in
how you handle the border between
history and fiction and in the in order
to take history and be able to make it
such a great read such as that opening
paragraph yes what hap
how do you what's your philosophy or
practice about do you really know that
he looked this way and he looked that
way
that he as the man he approached he
thought that i mean how close do you
stay to the text and what what's your
practice in this in this uh in this case
again i was asked the different lines
between fiction and history and how
close to someone stayed to the text and
uh in this case i didn't have to
you know even worry about it because the
the data is so rich
um because we actually have the
description by the general of of how he
was sitting in his sedan chair and as
general uh had guessed quite correctly
two other senior people raced the news
of the episode to uh to the emperor in
beijing anyway so he got that right he
was pretty sure they would uh
and also
uh
we actually know
uh from the confession of the messenger
where he'd been standing and we know
from so everything in this um is
i mean maybe with some you know changes
in phraseology but certainly not
altering the altering the basic uh
material in this
i thought a lot about this in this book
there is there's no way i could have
made this story up at any level it kept
completely surprising me i don't believe
that one should of course make make it
up and and claim it is history and and i
know that's some a bit of a tangle in
some in some books at the moment
uh and i've been uh well
you know sometimes i've actually made up
a line like the last line of the
question of who
uh but then i say in the notes that this
is my line and it's based on two or
three sources anyway
and i know that recently you know some
famous books have made up great chunks
of fake dialogue i've never done that
and i don't think one should as a
historian i think it's a different line
uh
so that one can be a historical novelist
and good luck it's a great genre
but the historian i think should
you know recreate the living dialogue
now the
different line the utterly different
problem is that of course you can find
an archival source of
wonderful looking dialogue
but the guys may be lying through their
teeth now that's a
that's a different problem so it's a
source but it may be full of lies
and then you're torn about whether to
use that if it suits your purposes or or
you can use your notes to say well this
is what they said but maybe they didn't
really mean it
we have in the case of the letter
the actual letter has not survived
but we have the summary by general yue
of the letter and then we have the
emperor's summary of the letter
uh when he wrote this big transcript
uh and the curious thing about this
emperor young jung which made me so
puzzled about him is that he he was
willing to publish all these accusations
against himself
now it's possible jung jung cut for all
time
charges even more horrible than the ones
that he printed
but really the charges against him are
so grim
that if there were more you know we've
still got quite enough i mean uh
he
the general didn't dare send um
his emperor the letter
when the general races the news
to beijing he has a very interesting
comment he says he he describes
everything i've i've said including
where the sedan chair was and where he'd
been and we know so that is is accurate
historically
but the uh the general says i've got the
letter here
but the charges against your majesty are
so repulsive
uh that i don't feel i can send it to
you without special authorization
so what he did because these were very
careful people this is why they were
senior bureaucrats in china they're very
careful
uh the general said i am giving
this letter i'm giving the copy i mean
not the card i'm giving the original of
this letter to the governor of shanxi
proven and
together we have sealed it in a special
box
and we will keep it there till we
receive your instructions
so we have the knowledge of what how he
summarized the letter to the emperor
and then the empress summarized it to
the chinese people
uh and then we have the emperor's
response which uh he wrote on the
document which was then returned to the
general
what you idiot what uh
the emperor wrote on the on the letter
was
when you hear
barking of dogs
or snarling of wild beasts
why worry send me the letter
which i thought was quite a phrase so
i'm a dog lover exercise
i found i felt a little bit sad about
the first part but the snarling of the
wild beast he said don't worry just send
it to me so the original was sent by
courier uh taken out of its box and then
raced across china
but somewhere it vanished nobody's found
it in the archives and
maybe it got shredded i don't know
how did those things survive the
cultural revolution yes the question how
did they survive the cultural revolution
well one of the the the intriguing
things about the cultural revolution uh
which was so tumultuous and destructive
in many levels
is that china's actual official archives
were not uh were not trashed
they must have been kept guarded
in 1966 when the cultural revolution
began these archives had not been
widely made accessible um
even to foreign scholars
and with almost no exceptions not to
western scholars
that's why so many of us went to taiwan
for our graduate work of my age because
we could go to taiwan and jankashek had
conveniently taken a lot of the archives
so a whole generation of american grad
students went to taiwan but in in the
cultural revolution
it was not exclusively but it was mainly
uh either
a certain amount of of
uh public
building you know architecture buddhist
sculptures again where
the the terrible things going on in
afghanistan you know with the buddhas
heartbreaking but
a huge amount of buddhist sculpture was
destroyed in in china as well at the
time
uh in in public places and temples
but the major
painting collections as far as i know
no a provincial museum had its painting
collections trashed or its porcelain
collections i don't think anywhere uh
and certainly not in in beijing and the
archives were not just destroyed
red guards would destroy their own
archives the famous dossier system in
china so those who believed they were
being criticized you know or their lives
are being ruined would break into their
own archives in their schools and and
destroy their dossiers if they could
uh but i don't know any examples of
national archival treasures being
destroyed sorry i haven't i've ignored
the group to my left uh anyway that's it
it's rather a miracle but they they did
survive and presumably someone somewhere
ordered uh these uh archives left alone
um people say usually people said it was
probably joe and lie but all sorts of
other stories are emerging about joe and
ly now so we can't be quite sure he's
he's appearing as a much tougher
character than we used to know can i
just have any belly good people here
yeah
uh is it known what became of the
messenger whether he uh heard of his
betrayal for example
and what his eventual fate was yes uh we
we do know the the messengers fate
he was eventually killed
but it took the emperor uh by order of
the next emperor uh it's part of the
complicated story but i still don't want
to give too much away
but he was uh he was pardoned along with
zhang jing after being again tortured
and interrogated for a long time
uh
and there's one episode in the in fairly
near the end of the book which again
there's so many things about this
completely surprised me but the the
messenger was actually used as a
lecturer
uh when the
young ching emperor ordered this book
the transcript of the trial
after distributing it in in china proper
and and also in taiwan
uh jung jung ordered the daijuemilu this
text taken to gansu and beyond that to
the edges of what later became xinjiang
province in the far west
and um jiangxi his name was jiangxi the
messenger had been kept in beijing
apparently i'm not sure whether under
house arrest or what but he'd he'd
stayed in beijing and in 1732
uh the emperor orders him to go with a
with a sort of a scholarly delegation to
the far west
where apparently he was meant to lecture
because some of
his actions were described in that
transcript as well
so he was
after that he was allowed to return home
and so the the chief conspirator and the
messenger
were both actually at home with their
families when the emperor died in 1735.
as far as we know jiangxi was not given
cash and he was not given a job so the
messenger didn't do so well uh and he
must have been pretty fed up with his
teacher by this time um
getting back to this this question very
good question about the sources i
uh i would love to have had the
messenger re-meet the teacher but i
couldn't find that they ever did
so
i i i don't bring them together i just
suggest that they could have seen each
other because there was an overlapping
month but i do that editorially there's
just one month when they're both back at
home within about 15 miles of each other
and in the text i openly speculate in my
voice saying that did they meet did
either of them make the decision to go
and see the other and it would have been
quite a meeting
i think uh
but we we don't know
anyway so he lived until 1735 or maybe
very early 1736.
john he was from a big family the
messenger was from a quite a big family
um and his a lot of his family were
involved his brothers and so on turned
out to be involved in various ways so
um
i think there's
right here then i come forward yes
i was particularly struck by your
recounting of the 28 episodes
that was televised on the subject matter
in in the prc
and i wanted to ask you as a historian
what do you think
the chinese people
take away from this historical lesson
nowadays
yeah that's that's an intriguing
question related to the the tv series
and then really reflecting on what the
chinese people take away from such a
story i have to say hey that i have not
seen the the young
uh program i've seen one once one
episode uh which wasn't dealing with
zheng jing so i've only got other
people's summaries you know to build on
but the zheng jing case this case was
only one you know bit of one of the
episodes as i understand it
what the chinese people take away from
this is to me again it obviously has to
be a guess uh because i haven't
specifically sort of i guess i haven't
specifically asked people in china what
they thought of it when it came out
um videos are available in this country
i know that but i've
i haven't had a chance to well i suppose
i've had a chance i didn't see it or i
haven't seen it
i think it says
well it could be interpreted in a lot of
ways one is that there are
fairly intriguing echoes of of some of
the things done particularly under mao
but even later for instance after the
tiananmen
uh demonstrations and massacre
what we have here is a uh
what youngjung practiced
in in this case what youngjung practiced
in the 1720s through to 1730
in the case of of zhong jing the chief
conspirator
is
evidence of wrongdoing
arrest intensive interrogation
the beginning of
contrition
the writing of a full confession the
demand that this be rewritten
a public recantation
uh after various kinds of essentially
struggle sessions through through these
writings and the compulsion to respond
uh followed by a full confession
and a written apology and statement of
guilt
when this was published
the conspirator is allowed back to the
welcoming arms of his hometown and uh
this has some of the hallmarks to me
certainly of rectification or jung fung
or whatever wants to call i mean that
process i think is oddly similar maybe
not oddly i mean is rather similar to
what many many chinese went through from
yemen onwards indeed so
whether chinese would really think of
that one stage i i mentioned to somebody
maybe it was in an interview that i said
that perhaps a good many chinese reading
about this would have a wry smile even
if they were being watched by
authorities from the party i mean they
must surely think for
this this ring's rather unpleasantly
true
whether there are deeper or you know
other complicated analogies between
the nature of power itself
the power of the bureaucracy itself
again using that episode of the
bureaucrats anger at the emperor is
instructive but there isn't exactly a
very neat parallel in china because
i think the bureaucrats under the
people's republic certainly lost
the ability to criticize mao in this way
and
there was recently i thought a very
moving study of dun tor who was the uh
the the uh editor-in-chief of people's
daily i guess
he committed suicide in 1966. so
when dunk taught committed suicide as
the cultural revolution was building up
you know it was really a symbol of the
end of uh even even moderate criticism
and um
joe and leia who's mentioned joe and i
had been silenced i think in 1959 when
he was forced to issue a public uh
self-criticism and then mao rejected it
and and joe and i was made to issue a
second and i don't think he really spoke
up again pung dawai was silenced after
luchan in 1959
so i don't get any sense that 148
bureaucrats would have said dear mao
jushi we will in fact
we'd rather not have a great leap
forward i mean i don't think
i don't get a sense of that
widespread orchestrated kind of
you know
attempt to keep a solid front
it gets to the heart i mean it does get
to the heart of bureaucratic systems i'm
not sure if there are easy parallels
between the two
but that kind of struggle and
rectification and recantation
publication and reabsorption into the
community
that is part of i think what uh has been
worked on
in the in the people's republic
people might think of others let me go
to the back here yes
and some of the other rebels here are
people that you get to know exclusively
as they as they are interrogated
um and maybe trying to make their case
but anyway not exactly in circumstances
of their choosing which is usually how
we get to know about rebels in history
anyway so how how can you work with that
yes well okay how do we get to know the
character of zhang jing and and uh the
related question is related is it brings
in the point of when you're dealing with
legal sources or treason sources
obviously you're going to have the
police record and that is always a bias
a very biased kind of sample then i
think you said how could i live with
that or how could i handle how could i
work with it yeah
well um
as i would say um
you as a historian you take what you got
you take what there is
you try and work out to some extent um
what this man's
world was like and i've always enjoyed
doing that as a historian we have um
we have a gazetteer very good gazetteer
of yongshin county well actually it's
rather it's not a very good it's rather
clumsy because it's here but it's uh
from um
uh
from about
1740
and it summarizes a kang ship here at
gazette we can tell in other words quite
a lot about the demographics of the area
the crop failures the different things
that went wrong
we can tell when
zheng jing seems to have been accurately
reflecting on his time
and when he may be making things up or
exaggerating but maybe those events just
never got in the local history
i should point out for the others here
who don't not interested in chinese
history so much that every single county
of china had its own local histories
which were often very very good which
were usually done by scholars
on average i would say every 60 or 70
years for every county usually sort of
after a long generation they would be
redone
so obviously because of human memories
they go in cycles like this the the
memories are densest nearer the time and
so
in any gazetteer or history the data
will fall off more than 60 or 70 years
behind as people have died
who could bear witness as it were but we
have a we have a good sense of the
community
uh zheng jing also gave uh he wrote
uh quite a lot about himself uh in a
confession when he was in hunan when he
was in changsha
and that's actually a very interesting
document because the
at one stage the interrogators gave up
for a bit they they proved he was a
traitor beyond any doubt um but he was
in such a state uh by this time he'd
obviously sort of really cracked under
terrific pressure uh and and they they
summarized the case to date for the
emperor and then they said actually
we've just we've now just given paper
and brush to tangjing and we've asked
him just to write you know about his
earlier life and so on and we'll send
that to you later
and that exists that's been preserved in
the beijing archive so we have a it's
not exactly under constant police
pressure but obviously he knows it's
maybe going to be read by the emperor
the startling thing is the emperor read
all this stuff with his despite his 16
hour days i mean he he had time for this
case
and that tells us some small things like
the fact that zheng jing
got away
or thought of getting away to sachiwan
his family thought that things were so
bad in hunan that they might emigrate
and he tells us about his marriage we
know
for those here in anthropology or
sociology we know that he married into
his wife's family and went to live with
his father-in-law which is usually a
sign of being somewhat on the economic
outs in china but instead of moving in
you know ship of the wife that moves
into your family and you can actually
lose some face i think by moving into
your wife's family but we know that he
did and we know the name of his
father-in-law and his uh
his wife's uncle
who he respected
so we can piece together what he was
like
as a teacher we know
his some of his comments on on various
events
his own books uh don't seem to have
survived except for his public
recantation
but the emperor yongjung's quotes from
xing jing's writings a lot
uh and in his so in that huge volume the
four volume
we have a lot of summaries of um
zheng jing's writings admittedly those
are by the emperor
but they're not quite the same as
constant police confession
i think i can't say that i particularly
liked him or really got to know him
intimately but i felt i knew a good deal
about sort of what he was trying to do
and i didn't
go into here
the text that he read and the vision he
had for china but for
the the china scholars here um zheng
jing was interested in the fungien
system the the
the trans this is of translators feudal
but that's not the point at all it's not
a feudal system it's a it's a less
centralized system in china that they
believed had once been followed in which
china was in smaller units and you knew
the local officials and people could
meet regularly in the local community
you know in in what were called the
community compacts or
where you get together in a community
and discuss problems of politics so
we we i got a fair sense of what his
visions were he seems to have been
pretty reckless i guess he was clueless
as
as
he i mean it wasn't a very effective
plot
and yet on the other hand if you're a
school teacher in south east hunan
trying to overthrow emperor jung jung
you know it's not a very easy thing to
do and one of the ways would be to um
locate a general who might back you and
another would be to
get the general to agree to
uh to move you know
and another would be to get somebody to
deliver a letter to the general anyway
who's surrounded by bodyguards and
outriders
uh how i mean you can't just walk into
the generals yaman and say
here's a secret letter because they it
would be torn open and then you'd be
run through with a knife you know i mean
you couldn't do it
uh or you'd be i mean you would never
reach the general so i think the the
teacher was extremely skillful in
delivering it on the road i think that
was the way to do it yeah if i'd had a i
would have delivered it on the road it
was your only chance to sort of run
across the road you're not going to get
general yay he's going to be guarded
around the clock and with very tough
people and his door keeper you know
you're not going to get through the
gates there's huge gates when you've
seen the chinese yarmouth you're not
going to get through that with a letter
so by running across the street he he he
actually got them got the man to read it
and then for a dizzying hour and a half
or more uh the general having read the
entire letter which was astounding not
just received it but read the entire
thing the general then says he's joined
the conspiracy so you must have been
wild with glee just for a little bit
you'd actually got two out of three of
the crucial status any trouble is he
then betrayed you uh but so you can't
get everything right
but two out of three is is pretty
remarkable for us a small village school
teacher to get
and then to occupy the emperor of
china's time for the next six years
obviously not all his time but a chunk
of it
all the way through
of course he was doing huge other things
like trying to conquer sinjanga
i had a lot of stuff to do and and
reforming the whole economic system as
scholars have shown but he did pretty
well okay on that note i think i really
must stop i love the topic but you can
read all about it in the book so thanks
for coming okay
[Applause]
and do i have some books to sign maybe
jonathan spence is a china scholar and
author of treason by the book
it explains the conspiracy trial behind
an attempted chinese coup during the
18th century it's published by viking a
division of penguin putnam for more
information visit them online at
penguinputnam.com
book tv features history books each
weekend saturdays at 11 pm eastern and
sundays at 8